My point of view for what it's worth is
that I don't think terrorism is very
important and I think we make it
important.
And by making it important,
we make it important.
Uh,
it does not matter very much.
A terrorist incident is happening.
It's an accident.
It,
it affects the people directly affected
by it,
but terrorism does not threaten states.
It doesn't threaten the integrity of
America or Britain,
that they can't invade us.
They can't do serious damage to our
economy unless we let them.
They cannot affect our values,
our democracy,
anything like that,
unless we let them.
Um,
they are.
They are to all intensive purposes,
useless criminals.
They simply blow things up and kill
people.
The early point at which they threatened
us is by our reaction to them.
They have no standing whatsoever other
than in terms of our reaction to them.
And our reaction to them is conditioned
by the publicity.
We give them a,
they depend upon publicity.
The multiplier publicies what makes the
Terrorism Act,
terrorist.
Otherwise,
it's just a killing.
That's why very few terrorist incidents
occurred in autocratic and dictatorial
countries.
They don't get any publicity.
They get publicity where we give them
publicity and it's that publicity that
they feed.